scientists alone and Doolittle in the
developing world politicians and
entrepreneurs must also get behind them
a laureate who pursued his ideas about
quasicrystals against fierce opposition
Dan Shechtman has equally strong
opinions about just how to apply science
you know it's really incredible how
something like the fivefold rotational
symmetry could completely change the
paradigm of crystallography I'm really
proud of Dan 4 persisting with his idea
in the face of so much criticism
Peace Prize winner josé ramos-horta
sees science is crucial to the
developing world but only if the
politicians can get on board it's really
going to be a policy makers like him
that are going to influence how science
can impact development
many people think education is the key
but it's not that simple so when you
come to a field like science which is
considered as an international family
how important do you think that we
should convey it in the native language
rather than English or some other global
language God you know frankly in our
native language like today I was
listening to one of the fascinating
topic on proteins how you're going to
translate that into that own language so
sometimes some of our native languages
simply not possible you have to be
practical about it we have faced this
question well over a hundred years ago
in Israel when we opened the first
University in Israel it's got the
Technion from which I am and for several
years the techni did not open because
there was a big argument what language
to teach in should it be German because
most of the teachers came from Germany
or should it be Hebrew proponents of
German said well we have all the
terminology in German and there is
practically nothing in Hebrew also
Hebrew said well if we do not develop a
technological language here where will
we do it they won and we have developed
the vocabulary for technology and for
many years the Technion was called the
Hebrew Technol of Haifa and the language
was in the name I think that it is
extremely important develop the
technology language in your language is
mentioned teaching in your own language
we have 11 official languages it's going
to be really difficult to teach every
individual community in the
language I suppose from a basic level
it's easier but when you get to high
school it gets more and more difficult
than the resources to translate
everything becomes really a problem so
in India like we have almost like more
than 30 local languages and we are
dealing a code pretty well with this
issue that is most of our primary
education happens in our own language
when you're taught a subject like
science where the understanding of the
basic concept is quite crucial for your
development in the future your native
language which you have been brought up
is quite easier than some other language
you know which oh yeah we should gain
which you're taught in the school yeah
but this is this attention there because
I mean I when I was actually when I was
teaching in South Africa I saw this
because I was teaching you I liked 12th
grade mats and you know you're teaching
the kids and they don't understand what
I know in gradient or slope is ice which
I would switch to sauna and also they
understand but when they take the exam
it's all gonna be in English my I'm I
think I'm a surviving witness of that I
was pretty much taught using fennec our
own language at primary level a bit of
English at high school so I had a lot of
catching up when I go to university
I mean English II I'm German you're
talking English would I survive here
with my language if I was taught
everything in my own language you do you
think this the time has come such that
each country particularly in the
developing world should start looking at
developing technological methods based
on challenges that are local or do you
think we should still stick to the old
system of education that's international
my approach you're from Cape Town I'm
from Cape Town right we have two South
African presentative here you are -
you're from Pretoria and you have
probably the largest
remote education system in South Africa
right what is the name of your ISA
Unisa unit fantastic system you teach
the world look you can teach every tribe
within South Africa but the point is
that you want to reach everybody basic
education for all is key to development
of the
country basic education for all you have
a vast reserve of platinum and gold okay
you are already world experts on some of
these issues then you have easy to us in
South Africa they do just that but to
prepare the people to work in these
institute yes you have to have maybe
more chemical engineering and more
chemistry and more physics develop the
strength of the country but isn't one of
the strengths of the country that it has
the problems itself so it understands
the context of the problems as well you
know countries in Africa understand the
problems in the say cold chain delivery
and that requires certain technological
solutions that if you're sitting in you
know Cambridge you might not understand
or appreciate and there's require
scientific solutions but also requires
knowing the local context there has to
be a collaboration between the west and
the east or the developed and the
developing nation right but the funding
might not be there to do that science
like and I think you know there's a lot
of these orphan diseases orphan causes
where there's not an incentive to do
research a lot of them are problems that
affect the developing world like a lot
of these you know Chagas disease sickle
cell disease a lot of new research
hasn't been done or a lot not the same
scope of research that could be done on
these reefs these problems yep but in
those developing nations they are not
even getting enough funding for to
address all those issues but you know
when you go to some developed nation
maybe they'll be having a fund for such
a long or they won't fund those things
there's no funding for that the funding
is for cancer in the u.s. in terms of
forces from outside actually I'm very
interested in your perspective on this
pressing ramos-horta
you mentioned I think of some of your
speeches about this idea of a Asian fund
for sustainable development like a
regional pool fund did you envision some
of that funding going to science and
technology research I put forward this
challenge in numerous speeches in the
context of a controversy over climate
change Asians
because of the population pressure in
Asia that alone gives responsibility to
Asia Asia as people extract a lot from
nature
just for survival so I propose why not
an Asian road map on climate change and
sustainable development putting together
an Asian fund of 100 billion dollars
over the next 10 years 20 years
investing in saving the forests that
Asian destroyed over decades saving in
the lakes the rivers disease that Asians
destroyed but also that money goes into
innovative research into technology
renewable energy today there's so much
liquidity in Asia you know from China to
India and technology in Japan in China
in Korea that could make Asia really
leading the rest of the wall on
sustainable development on preventing
you know the continuing deterioration of
our global environment but I'd like to
know what difference can I make
and I mean you mentioned the new master
class about the brain drain that happens
so as soon as we actually managed to get
along this path a little bit the people
leave and I go to move you know nicer
institutions with more capabilities to
do nicer work so do you have an idea of
how we can firstly influence the
politicians to make this a reality and
you know how do we attract the
scientists back okay by creating the
right conditions for them to come back I
can tell you what we do what we do in
Israel we educate graduate students that
mean masters and PhD we do it in Israel
then we send them abroad for postdoc
position then we choose the best to
bring them back the most successful we
bring them back what is the solution the
solution is to start building capacities
in developing countries that will
attract the brains back it's not always
about you are not paid enough in in your
home country if the problem is that you
don't have the right scientific
fear or the environment you don't have
that academic excellence around you
Shipman's answer also for me was a
little bit lukewarm in the sense that
you know he says are but they created
this wonderful environment where they
can go back and go and find the postdocs
that lift and bring them back but for us
that doesn't exist yet so it's extremely
difficult to create that yourself to go
and fetch these people and bring them
back so I think the challenge suto
remains and so the question now is how
do you think from your point of view how
your study can be implemented I'm
interested in tuberculosis and HIV
related infections TB and HIV are real
problems which need urgent attention and
science has been done in basic science
level in clinical science level also in
hospitals and public health level but
there's being a lack of faster
implementation of what has been
discovered by scientists so I think we
need to provide a platform of a good
communication where scientists are
involved in government and government is
involved in basic disappearance so you
have two categories scientists and
governments and in the opinion that you
talk they should be a platform a very
very thick layer in between which are
the people that do and these are the
industrialists these are the companies
these are the intrapreneurs this is the
intermediate between them you don't talk
to governments you talk to industries
and it's true followed in poorer
countries even in a country like India
it's not so easy to convince the
corporate private sector to finance
something that doesn't have immediate
result therefore the government is the
best almost the only potential source of
funding for research the key is that the
student academic aspiring scientists is
smart enough to identify who in the
government who among the politicians
he's the most inspiring the most
promising charismatic go and talk to him
convince him make him your advocate and
if he is convinced by your project then
he will be the one together with you we
will not be the prime minister or the
rich corporate sector to put some money
in your research so I think that the
under-representation of the scientists
in the government bodies is a problem
you don't expect the politicians to
understand each and every word the
scientists talk to because we are
talking a different language so along
with the industrialists scientists
should be finding you know some
representation in the government bodies
it is one of the answers to the issues
which we are facing right now so the
government that industrail is the
society everyone should be you know
contributing today oh you will go to the
UN no question about it okay fine my
work one of the difficulties is that
it's on sickle-cell disease which is in
neglected disease there's not much
funding out there globally because it
affects mostly people in sub-saharan
Africa it is thin not enough money yeah
okay so one of these issues is why is
very interested in this Asian
Development Fund is actually a quick
question to all of you is has anyone
here heard of the global R&D treaty
anybody global R&D - yeah I did not hear
about it yeah so I think this is a big
problem this is a the waho is
negotiating with every country
contributing point zero one percent of
their GDP to fund basic or basic and
applied research in global health issues
that are neglected such as sickle cell
disease Chagas leishmaniasis all these
things and almost every scientist I
talked to and even other people don't
have never even heard of this and it was
tabled was kicked down the road five
years by the US and Europe but if
scientists were more engaged or knew
about these opportunities and we can
save the community yes we want to do
this research and we would do it you
know and we want to work together and
solve these problems but we can maybe
have some more influence on the policy
scientists visa via the politicians the
companies in between for those Cazale
they weren't I don't think necessary
thing you outside the box yeah but
shitman was quite inspiring on the fact
that okay you don't have to wait for
the government or the you know funding
body used to go but they did but the
thing is a lot of these research things
where they haven't when these other
industries haven't come in because they
won't because there's no money to be
made yes there's no one to exploit in
these things so that's where you need
these other policy solutions both of
them were I think in politics and
science are two different channels that
you know parallel channels that that
will never meet I think we have to you
know get out of this ideology and have
to be they have to be a meeting place of
both nothing happens yes so these are
brilliant ideas and concepts and
structured and well thought-out but yeah
in terms of real difference in how we're
really going to make an impact that easy
well and I think it comes to education
we talked a lot in the discussion about
how we need to educate the public about
science but I think that scientists need
to know more about the policy and get
more involved I thought one of the
things that was interesting is as
scientists we don't necessarily know
about the policy that we can affect like
nobody news about the global R&D treaty
and we're not in getting involved in the
politics but Lee is obviously some of
the best and the brightest of their
countries and I believe there are many
more like them
governments in their respective
countries should cherish these young
scientists what they are doing they're
finding solutions to problem that affect
humanity as a whole
you